let's get more now at TW Washington
correspondent Stefan Simmons Stefan the
president is hoping his primetime appeal
will build public support for his border
plan how likely is that unlikely I would
say if you are referring to the entire
public of the United States he has the
backing of conservatives and Republicans
and of course of his base they are
overwhelmingly
for the President and they're also
supporting overwhelmingly the stance and
the argument the president makes
everybody else pretty much is a little
bit more differentiated and says again
the president is making up or forcing a
crisis at the southern border of the
United States on the American people
doesn't get his facts straight and is
keen on fulfilling a a campaign promise
which he now can't with a Democratic
House of Representatives because as you
pointed out before in the report again
with the earth with the clips this
Democrats are in no way prepared to
follow the America the president's lead
and give him what he wants 5.7 billion
dollars for the border wall okay this
was the president's key campaign promise
building the wall let's take a listen to
some more of what President Trump had to
say the border wall would very quickly
pay for itself the cost of illegal drugs
exceeds 500 billion dollars a year
vastly more than the 5.7 billion dollars
we have requested from Congress the wall
will also be paid for indirectly by the
great new trade deal we have made with
Mexico Stefan so who will be paying for
this wall if it moves forward the
American taxpayer well because as the
president says and explains here the
follow up deal of NAFTA is a not even
ratified by Congress and Democrats have
already said they a have questions and
will have or some kind of opposition to
the to ratifying this deal number one
and secondly
he got his facts wrong there too it
doesn't work like this that if you have
revenue or more tax income from a trade
deal you make that this will be
earmarked for a border wall so as it's
not gonna happen that any follow up deal
from for NAFTA for the will pay for the
border wall it will be if he gets what
he want the American taxpayer who will
pay for the bottle wall which will be
there actually different to what he
promised in his campaign that Mexico
will pay well the Mexicans as you know
I've said no way that they will be
paying okay a Stephan in in the run-up
to this address there was a lot of
speculation that Donald Trump would
declare a national emergency to allow
him to build the wall without
congressional approval he didn't mention
that in this speech is that still an
option that is still an option but more
so maybe in his mind and in reality
because reportedly he was told by his
aides and by his legal advisers that he
would fairly quickly run into trouble
and that the declaration of an emergency
national emergency would not work for
him and it makes sense the opposition
and therefore Democrats but also
independent observers and experts have
said if the president is is going to
declare a national emergency this will
be immediately almost immediately a case
for the courts this can take month weeks
years even to be resolved and at the end
the national emergency will not
translate into a national emergency
executive order or something like this
so there's a good good chance that he
will never ever exercise this right
however we're talking about Donald Trump
here so when I say there's a really good
chance it won't happen there's also a
good chance that he will do it anyway
you